let's talk about something that uh i
think needs to be discussed
you uh have had this incredible success
with ant-man
people love the ant-man franchise
and whenever uh
someone achieves this uh iconic status
in our culture as a superhero
one of the uh perks is that you get an
action figure yeah
your action figure came out of ant-man
and i want to talk to you about the face
of your action figure this is the actual
uh what an [ __ ]
ant-man's a dick yeah look at that guy
right
or a stroke victim i don't
that's like one of those you should use
this in hospitals if you see this
get that person to a hospital right away
for people who are suffering from bell's
palsy
did you have any uh any say on this guy
no
no when i saw it i just started laughing
so hard
uh i because
it's like somebody some guy designed
this or
could have been a woman i don't mean to
yeah you know it could be anybody could
be anybody
but it really makes me laugh that
somebody put time into this
and sculpted it and is that a panel of
people like that had to go through
numerous people like yeah yeah the smirk
definitely this merc
someone came in and went make it look
like this that's what they did
yeah somebody signed off on it
yeah it's true um but that's it that's
yeah how do your you know i'm just
curious how do your
yes
look right there i think it's terry
bradshaw yeah
yeah oh no it's not it's not gary
bradshaw
it's andy's right in the dark it looked
like terry bradshaw caught it
[Laughter]
he's not wearing pants uh you know
uh this has got to be interesting how do
your kids feel about the fact that
you're
a superhero do they are they how aware
they've got to be aware of the ant-man
phenomenon
oh yeah yeah very much so they're you
know they're um
they're kind of well they're not grown
but they're 14 and nine right
and so uh they're very aware and see all
the marvel films and they love the
marvel films and their friends
go see them uh but that's a pretty new
sensation uh not to quote in excess but
i will
um the uh yes that's the level of my
isn't it it is okay i didn't know i
forgot it's been a long time since i
thought about
that wonderful band from australia give
me what you need give me what you need
i i loved nxs i loved them too yeah they
were fantastic we've totally gone off on
a terrible tangent
and i'll bring it back no no we don't
ever have to get out of this cul-de-sac
we can stay right here but
welcome to our 80s podcast did you know
that i once went i saw in excess one
sweat
by the way i do say everything wrong and
my kids make fun of me for it i say ice
ice cream like i say you're emphasizing
the wrong thing
it drives them insane right anyway
ice cream so you say to your kids hey
let's go get some
ice cream it's my
i'm not even but i'm i'm not even aware
of it right
i say i say things incorrectly yeah i
don't realize it yeah it's all fine it's
all good my wife says tv
she says it's tv tv i'm like what
no no no no she says oh god i've already
i've already gone off the rails
tv tv she says it yes where is she from
uh she's from new jersey oh i asked for
a reason because i got to meet bob dylan
once briefly backstage and someone
pushed me forward in bob dylemazer and
i've been on the air at that point for
about 10 years
never met him since the iconic bob dylan
i got pushed in front of him he had the
little thin mustache at the time and he
went
i know you from the tv
[Applause]
and then that was it i was pushed away
and i was gone
but that's how he said it i know you
from the tv
that sounds almost more traumatic than
my terry bradshaw and that's
yeah hey fully clothed bob dylan saying
tv
is more frightening than a naked terry
bradshaw and i'm picturing with a
mustache and i'm just picturing floyd
the barber from
andy griffith show you from the tv
yeah exactly um but anyway about ant-man
the uh we just went to nxs
bob dylan and then ant-man okay here we
go my kids are my kids think
my kids think it's pretty cool but they
never you know it was the first thing
i've ever done that they have ever even
seen i grew up or i grew up they have
grown up knowing that i had this job but
it was never really
it's not part of our lives in that way
and my son when he was about
five they went to the first time he ever
really had any kind of awareness is he
went to a movie theater and there was a
movie poster in the theater that my i
had my face was on it and
so he and his friends thought that i
just worked at the movie theater
and i'm not so sure i ever did even
dissuaded him from thinking oh yeah
yeah i think it's good kind of thing
yeah yeah my kids still don't know what
i do
i go off and they think oh yeah he's in
real estate